we visit all the pages of the web we
actually render each page in a real web
browser so that
our ai can see the page just like a
human does you can see
the actual pixels the look of the page
so it's more than just a text of the
page
[Music]
mike tong thank you for being on my show
how are you all the way from
a silicon valley i'm doing well thanks a
lot for having me
i'm very excited to chat with you about
ai about your entrepreneurial journey
what you're doing at diffbot but we have
to go back to
being a child musician playing at
carnegie hall
what is that about how do you get to
play carnegie hall as a child
well um i think my story is similar to a
lot of
um chinese americans uh they're sort of
forced to play an instrument at a young
age
uh by their family but i i think um
you know the the main purpose of that is
just to learn discipline and learn
practice so yeah as a child i played
the violin for maybe i don't know about
18 years or so
before before college and i ended up
playing with the group at carnegie hall
that's that's remarkable so you you grew
up in taiwan right you're an immigrant
from taiwan
tell me a little bit about your
background and and moving
along with that background through
carnegie hall to a
to get to doing ai at stanford for your
masters
um well it's a lot to compress and a lot
of years to compress but but basically
i was born in taiwan i immigrated to the
us when i was about two years old
so don't remember too much about taiwan
from from back then
but my parents my dad came to the us as
a grad
student studying biochemistry and
he later on taught at universities as a
professor
in pathology and later
off spun and founded his own biotech
company you know that he's developing
actually
vaccines for um hiv and
even one for covid right now over in
atlanta
georgia wow and so i grew up in a very
entrepreneurial
family growing up in a very
entrepreneurial family what does that
mean you immigrated from taiwan you were
telling me about
what your father was doing but what does
it mean being in an entrepreneurial
family
well it just means i guess it was
something accepted you know or at least
not
not crazy to be an entrepreneur since it
ran into family i guess
um however you know while the rest of my
family is sort of like in biotech
in biology and i i worked at my dad's
lab actually growing up and i realized
that you know it's
i wasn't cut out sort of to do biology
um
i spent you know many hours waiting for
centrifuges to run
you know extracting dna and building
viruses and
watching various kinds of clear fluids
um develop and
uh you know i needed a faster iteration
cycle than that waiting days and days
for an experiment to run
and not knowing where you messed up
maybe like in day two
and that's kind of how i came to
computer science
so you so you're looking for this agile
approach
where you get to see results fast
iterate
pivot iterate and and get to and get to
deeper results and and you find your way
towards
stanford masters nai working in the ai
lab talk me a little bit about what
you're doing there and and what draws
you specifically to artificial
intelligence then
well i mean so it just started out
playing with computers developing
video games i think like a lot of the
typical story of a lot of computer
programmers
and after high school actually i instead
of going
directly to college i worked for about a
year at microsoft
as a software engineer because i thought
growing up you know microsoft is the
place where they really invented
software development right and i read
about bill gates story and then so uh
i went there i got to meet him like all
the interns are invited to his uh
house like over the summer i think back
then
so i got to go to his backyard and check
out his place
um and i learned a ton when i was at
microsoft so um
you know aft but i also realized i
probably don't want to work in a big
company for the rest of my life
um so after microsoft
what was it about the big company that
culture that then you said okay maybe
i'm
more into the small company space
well first i thought it was a great
experience actually working at microsoft
you know
i i learned an incredible deal about how
like professional software development
is done
but you know i realized you know i i
want to do something of my own i want to
uh
i you know my bosses and mentors when i
was working at microsoft
you know i had to really think do i
really want to be like that in 20 years
or 30 years
right um kind of doing doing that kind
of work and
i just wanted to do more um
and i wanted to work in a place that was
i was not constrained by the the
organization
where i was sort of like i think that's
why a lot of people do entrepreneurship
because um they can't really work for
anybody else
so throughout these experiences you're
you
are getting into the inter in more into
artificial intelligence
what do you actually do at stanford what
is your master's in and
what leads you then towards this idea
for div bot
yeah so i was i was interested in ai
i guess way before it was popular from a
pretty young age like when i was even in
high school i was like
developing neural networks to like to
trade stocks and stuff from
reading like a sentiment on on the very
nascent internet at that point in time
um so i had always been fascinated by ai
and building
intelligence systems at berkeley
you know i finished an undergrad at ecs
in about two years and then
quickly moved to um grad school at
stanford and i took a heavy
concentration in ai
and ai courses um and so
it was at around that time when uh there
was this data set that was being built
at stanford called imagenet which was
basically like a
you know a large collection of labeled
images um of
they basically used amazon mechanical
turk to label all these images that
are from google image search and i was
thinking okay how can we build like an
image net for
language because unlike vision right
like
the the human language what we're using
right now is what distinguishes humans
from animals right
like even my dog has computer vision he
can tell the difference between his bowl
and a toy you know a grassy field but
animals don't have anything like human
language right so i was thinking about
this problem and
why is there no like imagenet for
language even today there isn't really
something like that
and it's because there's way more
concepts that humans have created than
there are
you know like a thousand image classes
and it would take up to 50 man decades
in order to
uh build such a data set right so that's
when i started thinking okay what if we
could use ai to automatically construct
actually a structured data set of all
the concepts that human beings care
about
um and what greater resources there than
the internet itself and that
you know the internet i view is
basically kind of like the world's
largest man-made sensor
anything that's uh an important entity
someone's created a page for on the
internet
right and the only problem with the
internet is that it's not in a
structured format that's needed for
machine learning
and ai to use so i i started thinking
back then about
how can we actually convert the internet
into
actually like a structured data set that
then applications can use
wow fascinating so so you're starting so
that's the research that you're going
towards
and i i'm also aware that you've given
quite a few guest lectures at stanford
about knowledge graphs and about the
different work that you've done
in this field so so take me through this
entrepreneurial journey
how do you take a research question that
you're so excited about and translate
that into
a company that you're running along with
the work that you're doing at stanford
um well i wouldn't say it was a very
direct journey
so i don't think you you just start on
such a task like that directly
um during stanford um i was you know
doing this research
uh and you know uh sort of
i guess trying to delay from writing a
thesis
because it's very hard to come up with
like a breakthrough machine learning
algorithm
and so i was doing a lot of side things
like i was um actually working as a
patent attorney
taking the the patent bar and helping a
friend you know right past
to basically make money on the side as a
side hustle
um i actually ended up working for a
startup that one of um
my professors at stanford uh dr uh
professor uh prabhakar raghavan who's
now
um a very important person at google um
he um
he said i was taking his information
retrieval class
and then he pulled me aside after
basically the end of the class and said
hey i'm doing the startup
that i'm an advisor of you know and
would you join us i joined it as one of
the
sort of the founding engineers of course
that's what happens
yeah it's a it's a very common story at
stanford um that startup
um years later gets acquired by facebook
i also had um sort of did a project with
some buddies
uh called quick.tv that was like a video
search engine
that then we later sold to cisco right
so i had a couple acquisitions under my
belt and i had worked as a consulting
scientist at yahoo
on their search and on ebay on their
search so
um the trend here is i got a lot of
experience in building a search engine
like from scratch
um and uh these connections sort of paid
off later like ebay one became one of
the first customers of
different there's actually um a group in
ebay
in israel called the structured data
group that uses define
i actually i i'm good friends with that
group i worked with ebay closely
on some projects that i did and my
transition between high school and the
army
and and it's a really fantastic team
yeah well they they were a user of
diffbot and then
um some of those engineers there um
basically um just bought replaced
their work and then later we hired them
to join define
from one of the guys from ebay israel
fantastic
fantastic so so what is deathbot
and and i'd love to spend some time
hearing uh
another amazing founder story so you
know taking thinking through your
inner like you know the personal journey
that you're like you know
from descending from the company what
are some of the biggest hurdles that
you're going through
along what are some of the most
enjoyable moments of creating this
company
okay so the first question what is div
bot so basically diffbot
is um a search engine now how it differs
from google
the same how it's the same as google is
that we crawl the web right so we
we visit all the pages of the web we
actually render each page in a real web
browser so that our ai can see the page
just like a human does you can see
the actual pixels the look of the page
so it's more than just a text of the
page
and then what we do is how the ai comes
into play is
on every page on the web we're able to
classify that page into what type of
page is it is this a person page is it
an
organization page is it a product page
is it an image page
and we're able to automatically convert
this into structured information
right so like a structured record about
a person place or thing
and then what we build is what we call
the knowledge graph which is essentially
you know a structured database right so
how it differs when you
um use google for example what google is
is you type in a query
and then google gives you back a sorted
list of results right so google is
similar to a card catalog in a library
where it's directing you to other pages
to read right and then
uh google's business model is to auction
off basically your attention to the
highest bidder and advertisers
there's a trade-off i guess between
relevance and advertising
right and then um but google doesn't
actually contain the knowledge
it's actually just routing you to web
pages which you read
and then you gain knowledge from reading
those those results right
diffbot is actually doing the reading of
those web pages you know using our ai
assembling it into this structured data
set
and then returning back those facts
directly from
our index and so the reason diffbot is
useful
especially for people building
applications and businesses
is if you're building an app let's say
you
um cannot just directly access a search
engine
you need structured data to show in your
app and to use it in your app right
so for example like snapchat is one of
the customers of diffbot they
we power like the stories features those
articles news stories inside snapchat
we also power other search engines like
duckduckgo when you see like those news
tiles or
organization tiles if you are
like a business that has like a crm we
can actually
take every record in your crm and
automatically enrich and enhance it
using the information we have in the
knowledge graph
so think of it almost like um you know
like a professional
search engine that a business
application can use right
all of your other business tools that
you use um are not generally like ad
support supported
software um that's like consumer
software right
like your microsoft word uh or zoom
doesn't have like
a pop-up ad inside it and that's how
it's like supported
how do you how do you get to the to the
realization that this is even something
that's needed
so you know i if i were to even you know
as i am studying artificial intelligence
at stanford and i'm working on all
on a lot of these questions i wouldn't i
would never imagine like maybe i should
build a
competitive search engine that could
create structured data out of
the world wide web well so
you said the ai so you know that there's
basically like three
drivers right of improving ai
performance there's the hardware
the software and then the data right um
so i realized early on that the hardware
i can never really compete there i'm not
going to compete against intel
or you know tsmc or samsung and come up
with better hardware right nvidia
there's already billions of dollars
invested in that area writing that
better
the software well i was trying to
compete in that in grad school
developing new algorithms right and but
then
there's like google tensorflow there's
you know pi torch there's all this
the software is always getting better
and there's so many people coming up
with better algorithms all the time as
well
right but when you start to think about
data and you want to build an
intelligent system
you need structured data well what does
everyone do they end up just collecting
their own data
they end up just kind of rolling their
own for their own application using the
data they have
there isn't really like a kind of a
knowledge store where you can just kind
of say i want to import this data from
this source
and i have a core set of people
organizations or articles
or information to start out with that i
can tap into
and so that's an area where i saw there
is actually a gap
and looking at things like imagenet you
can see that it was actually this data
set that
resulted in this new revolution in deep
learning it wasn't actually any novel uh
new algorithm right that was invented
um because neural networks have been
around you know uh
since at least the 60s and 70s um
so it's what i realized hey um
why can't we build like an everything
store of data
um and structure the world's knowledge
and um
build like a new kind of search engine
for sure these intelligent
applications can use right so share with
me let's say a use case that i'm
building application that has something
to do with
sports right and let's say that i'm a
that i'm dealing a lot with uh with the
fifa
soccer tournament or with the nfl and
and i want to make use
of of of this knowledge database that
you're accumulating
by taking the world wide web and making
it into structured data
what would how would that use case look
like from your perspective
uh if if i were to want to use this bot
for example
yeah so um i can show you an example
um i'm not sure
so so with sports one of our customers
is called um
sports innovation lab and what they do
is basically they produce business
intelligence
for owners of like sports teams and
sports executives
right okay so they're using the
different knowledge graph in order to
track
like um what's developing all these
events in the sports world
the players the teams um they're using
it to track like which teams have like
covet covid
of which things are shutting down how
are things like reopening so it's
helping sports executives re-navigate
sort of the reopening like postcovid and
so they're using the knowledge graph to
keep track of all these things right
because
uh it seems like things are changing in
the news on a daily basis with each team
and each player
it's too much for like a human to keep
track of right amazing
we crawled the web keeping track of all
that what i'd love is that is that as
you explain this
we're going to put write a box right up
right above your head of how it's going
to look so
so how how does a company like that
interact with diff bot
on the on their day to day as they're on
on both of the application level but
also on the
on the consumer level yeah um i
i shared with you a link to basically
the
what how it looks like to the end user
but you can see basically
um there's this dashboard that shows
um a visualization across time
of various um
sporting world related events
you know as they relate to covet and
sports and so you can see
it's um it's sort of curated by the team
uh on each team it shows like you know
when
that see that uh that league was
postponed when it reopens like
um athlete data like whether a player
has covid
um wow
that's very and that's very very cool
that's
very very cool what was the what was the
most surprising part of the
startup journey for you until now
uh well i mean startup journey has so
many
surprises in it i guess um um i guess
with diff bottom
i'm i'm surprised by different use cases
of of
our technology at all the time right
every day you hear about
um one of our customers using it in a
way that you didn't expect the
technology
to be used in so i think that's one cool
thing about building like a platforms
kind of company
is that um the people are free to use it
in like lots of different ways that you
wouldn't have imagined
and it creates more innovation 100
it also requires some open-mindedness
and some creativity on your end to
accept it and
and to and to roll along with that
understanding that this is
that you're seeing these radically new
use cases that you didn't expect but
you're embracing them and now you're
now you're able to understand the
magnitude of what you're building mike
this was
really wonderful and i love what you're
doing i know that you're also hiring so
i'm guessing that if anybody here
is is into this kind of stuff and would
like to reach out i i can make the intro
that's okay with you
yeah definitely we're we're probably the
best place in the world
if you care about building automatic
knowledge graphs using ai
right from the whole web besides google
and bing we're the only other us entity
that crawls the entire internet so we
have our own
entire facility here in the bay area
that crawls the web and has a copy of it
how many people are you the company
right now um we are
a little less than 40 people right now
wow that's it
very very impressive it's mind-blowing
to me a team of less than 40 people
making sense of the entire internet
crawling the entire internet
and that's it that's just you know it's
a it was unbelievable when
larry and sergey attempted to do it in
1998 when the internet was it was this
small
it's even more impressive when you're
trying to do it when the internet is
this big mike before we leave i have to
ask you for three words that you would
use to describe yourself
um this is a tough question um to reduce
like a human just to like three bits but
i would say um if i were to only choose
three words
in the my entry in the different
knowledge graph it would probably be
machine learning engineer
um because that probably most describes
what i do like engineering machine
learning systems
that describes the core of you know what
i do as a ceo
i i love that mike thank you very very
much and this was really great i learned
a lot thank you for
being so generous with your time and
best of luck and stay safe and stay
healthy
great thanks for having me michael